s'agit de récupérer un attribut de la
souveraineté qui est le contrôle de
l'immigration
encore une fois lui d'essai pour une
immigration choisie
et si on sait que en provenance de
l'union européenne
c'est seulement 1 1 une personne sur sur
quatre qui correspond à un outil vient
pour occuper un poste de spécialiste
dans trois cas dans trois cas sur que
trois cas sur quatre se sont pas des
postes qui de spécialiste et ce sont des
postes qui peuvent être occupés par une
population suisse au chômage par des
travailleurs seniors par des apprentis
n'a rien à voir par rapport trop
d'étrangers au bassin d'étrangers moi
même je sais issus d'une immigration je
suis suisse s ii le jeune russe
on parle notre initiative les concentrer
vraiment sur la préférence nationale
al embauche voilà ça tout notre
initiative elle concerne que ça rien à
voir avec les étrangers au pas les
étrangers les cépages sont bienvenus le
dire on a ça on est happé multinational
et multiculturel à c'est vraiment ça
concerne l'ambush le travail pour que
nos citoyens ils sont ils sont les
moyens pour vivre dignement tout
simplement subvenir aux besoins de leurs
familles de leurs enfants
alors là c'est clair
veut mettre fin à la libre circulation
des personnes et aux mesures
d'accompagnement mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont d'une
protection tous les travailleurs
on sera peut-être pas compte mais en
protégeant les travailleurs qui viennent
travailler chez nous de l'étranger on se
protège aussi c'est ces mesures
d'accompagnement permettent l'extension
de l'école convention collective de
travail permettent aussi d'instaurer des
salaires minimums contiennent la
sous-enchère salariale
donc c'est une protection pour tous les
travailleurs qu'ils soient suisses
immigrés résidant ou frontaliers
[Musique]
oh